dix mille abonnés je suis vraiment
content c'est vraiment surprenant et
monstreux que avoir dix mille personnes
qui aiment lima est autant au point de
vouloir m'écouter entendre parler de
mater toutes les semaines c'est juste
génial
alors comme promis faire une petite faq
donc j'ai compilé quelques unes de vos
questions
donc vous avez été nombreux à demander
quel était mon parcours j'ai fait un
parcours ultra classique il s'est
général filières scientifiques premiè
res terminale s est pas mps y est
ensuite très mat donc au lycée louis le
grand et ensuite j'ai intégré l'école
polytechnique
j'ai continué plus dans les maths
appliquées et ensuite j'ai fait une
année en master à montréal quand on
maîtrise
ça c'est pour les québécois qui nous
regardent ça lui les québécois et je
peux parler quebecor l'eau j'ai obtenu
ma thèse à l'école polytechnique de
montréal en mathématiques appliquées
recherches opérationnelles stache
théorie des jeux tu fais pas mal de
théorie des jeux et ensuite j'ai fait
une année de pause doc
ça c'est ce qu'on fait après avoir notre
test donc la thèse ont fait trois quatre
ans où c'est déjà pas mal de face et la
recherche
et après on peut prolonger pour
continuer la recherche et le plaisir
avec des contrats à durée déterminée et
beaucoup de précarité mais son accord un
bon salaire en moins parce qu'on pose
dot malheureusement j'ai envie de dire
il est de plus en plus de postes dotés
de plus en plus difficile de trouver un
poste
après sa thèse est donc comment comme
tout le monde j'ai fait mon puzzle fait
une pause de midi au département
d'informatique du mighty sur des
problèmes d'optimisation s'appelle ans
en temps réel
online optimisation en anglais ces trucs
vraiment couvre des grosses notes de
crosse preuves font beaucoup de pages et
qui sont théoriquement à piger comme
j'avais appelé ça c'est à dire que
ça pourrait être appliquée oui comment
appliquer puis j'aime bien aussi le jeu
de mots sur le fait que c'est plus de la
théorie à la pratique
je trouvais des théorèmes et ensuite
après mon post doc et marty suis posé
beaucoup de questions existentielles
déjà fin d'un doctorat comme j'avais
trouvé le post doc g procrastiner le
moment de me poser des questions
existentielles à la fin de mon post doc
est là la fin d'une post doc
là je me suis vraiment posé beaucoup de
questions et je me suis dit qu'en fait
la recherche s'étaient pas tout à fait
ce que je voulais faire
même si j'adorais ça la recherche sûre
que psychologiquement notamment c'est
très très très difficile pourquoi on
passe vraiment son temps à ne rien
comprendre
gallery après ont consacré en papier
puis après que pas qu'ils soient publiés
c'est la guerre défendre son petit
morceau
bref j'ai senti que j'avais pas les
épaules assez larges pour faire de la
recherche
et puis que c'était pas vraiment ce que
je voulais faire le truc que je kiffe le
plus c'est pas forcément essayer de
trouver le truc qui va permet d'aller
être un tout petit peu plus loin dans un
domaine très très spécifiques
moi ce que j'adore c'est qu'ils playmate
j'aimerais j'adore explorer différents
champs des maths et de l'informatique
théorique et plus de la physique aussi
et voir des trucs de biologie aussi que
son coût j'adore j'adore explorer
différents trucs et la recherche c'est
pas très bon pour ça malheureusement la
recherche force à la spécialisation
ça c'est un truc des trucs qui m'a
beaucoup déplu avec la recherche et
alain verger commencez à vous garder à
ce scientifique ya quatre ans en 2012
en avril 2012 avec un blog s'appelle fan
forum 5 sera le point org
c'est en anglais cd long article le blog
marchait bien mais pas super bien
ensuite j'ai fait une chaîne youtube en
anglais qui a marché pareil bien une
passe super bien et halal phénomène
français youtube francophones à décoller
les décoller pendant que je faisais
encore mais michel en anglais choix
douze mois en même temps service
découvert y penser pendant que moment
j'étais déjà en train de faire des
vidéos en anglais
du coup après en avoir fait michel en
anglais pendant que j'étais post doc et
marty donc pas avec un rythme de
publication que j'ai aujourd'hui je me
suis dit que j'allais essayer de surfer
sur la vague francophone est gênant
c'est cinq fois roland français
j'arrêtais aussi au passage suis
vraiment lancer à temps plein dans la
vulgarisation et pas beaucoup d'argent à
libération c'est à dire que j'étais au
chômage en fait énorme coup de bol il ya
quelques quelques mois là j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait cette annonce qui passait
à le pfl clope est faible pour ce qui va
se passer l'école polytechnique fédérale
de lausanne tas à lausanne en suisse qui
juste au nord du lac léman
ce qu'on tire avec la france est en fait
on voit les montagnes de votre côté on
va traîner ça c'est du hadj aujourd'hui
on voit je vois là la france a de
l'autre côté des montagnes
il cherchait quelqu'un pour reprendre le
projet one dia qui fait sauter sur
l'occasion et j'ai pu reprendre en main
le projet one rida et c'est pour ça que
depuis quelques mois je suis là et je
suis surtout heureux d'être là alors
julien blanche on me demande ce que
j'utilise comme logiciel entre matlab r
octave ou mathematica j'utilise aucun de
ceux-là et toucher un tout petit peu à
ma cave pendant cinq minutes de ma vie
j'ai touché air aussi 5000 de ma vie
sans lui aussi mais sinon j'ai jamais
vraiment touché ses autres logiciels
comme j'ai dit je suis un mathématicien
théoriquement appliquée même si j'ai
programmé pendant ton dans ma thèse mais
c'était plus en java valentin drop me
demande quel était mon métier de rêve
quand j'avais quand j'avais 8 10 ans
j'étais tout petit et à quel point ce
que je m'en suis éloignée il ya eu dix
ans je pense que je regardais pas mal
fait pas sorcier
et puis je trouvais savoir [ __ ] ceci
étant dit je pense que nous n'avons
aucune idée de ce que je voulais faire
plus tard carence pas sorcier ça ne
semblait pas du tout un truc
envisageable comme carrière que j'ai me
dire c'est que voulait être président
des états unis d'amérique à quel point
je me suis éloigné du poste de président
des états unis d'amérique
depuis que j'ai quitté états unis c'est
un petit peu plus armé froid que ç'a
toujours été très doué
alors jérémy lengelé et aurélien
perdriau me demande pourquoi est ce que
je me suis lancé dans la vulgarisation
sur youtube en fait j'ai déjà plus ou
moins
pondu mais insisté sur le fait que
youtube c'est absolument incroyablement
génial que j'ai essayé de faire de la
vulgarisation autrement que via youtube
digérer fait ça sur blog et bien sûr
blocks absolument incroyablement génial
parce que il n'ya pas et beaucoup moins
de délais de publication peut être
publication dans la recherche mais ça
prend des années passées à chaud puis
j'ai publié quand j'avais écrit pour la
classe notamment ous avez pris mais
beaucoup beaucoup de temps avec avant
d'être publié pas de nouvelles pendant
cinq mois
c'est super galère il ya pas de feedback
rapide et des coûts ça empêche une
production régulière et rapide qui ça
rend tout ça très très difficile et j'ai
commencé aussi l'expert un bouquin bon
et les français c'est super gala ce que
va avoir tout écrit avant d'avoir
vraiment des feedbacks et ça prend des
mois et des mois fin c'est super galère
à côté de tout ça youtube c'est juste
génial youtube en voilà qu'en quelques
en deux journées de travail
gros son programme en deux journées
trail plein pour en faire une vidéo et
en deux journées de travail j'arrive à
sortir un truc qui est je trouve assez
bien quoi qui arrive à conduire le
message même mieux que si c'était par
écrit parce qu'il ya des scouts et
dynamique en plus à l'oral il ya
quelques années j'avais entendu james
quand même pas failli
qui disait que les maths doivent
communiquer à l'oral et a suscité assez
perplexe à ce moment là parce que je
n'ai pas fait beaucoup doral
même si j'adorais faire des
présentations orales et cette fois
fruité à l'oral ski moins rigoureux
manque aussi et tout mais aujourd'hui
j'ai complètement changé d'avis pour moi
youtube c'est vraiment la meilleure
façon de communiquer des choses à l'oral
les choses se passent beaucoup beaucoup
mieux qu'elle écrit s'il ya vraiment un
effort au préalable qui est fait pour
que le message passe très très bien à
l'oral
une fois qu'on a travaillé ce message
alors je pense qu'ils passent vraiment
mais super bien et du coup aujourd'hui
il se trouve que c'est beaucoup mieux
pour l'image des mathématiques pour le
développement de vulgarisation
scientifique pour l'amour des
mathématiques de faire des vidéos
youtube que l'écart des bouquins
ceci étant dit comme les autres tu dors
je pense que c'est un petit peu un rêve
de gosse aussi d'écrire un bouquin est
un éditeur me propose écrire un bouquin
j'ai une idée de boucane en tête du
secteur abattoirs blanc me demande
quelle caméra et qu'elle micro j'utilise
donc j'utilise mon caméra qui est un
canon hd video games
je suis en train de lire je suis je
connais pas bien on va perdre c'est pas
du truc de pro c'est la caméra c'est
vraiment premier pris le micro c'est un
suis là c'est un apn 33 57 et j'ai aussi
le h4n pour faire les voix off et
j'utilise famille en cas de problème sur
le devant il ya ce boucalais me demande
si un erasmus l école polytechnique
fédérale de lausanne ne vaut la peine
pour un mathématicien
alors étant employé de le pfl qui
promeut la recherche et l'éducation à le
pfl j'ai envie de répondre oui mais pour
être totalement honnête je connais pas
très bien le département de
mathématiques en fait je suis un
département d'informatique ihsi donc
pour les partenaires informatiques je
dis oui oui oui tout de suite dans le
pfl avait vraiment l'un des meilleurs
centres de recherche en informatique en
europe et voir au monde
j'ai entendu dire que dans un classement
elle était tombée huitième dans le monde
ce qui est vraiment au dessus de
n'importe quelle école française d'alors
les classements il ya plein de choses à
dire fricassée mais tout se vendait en
informatique théorique ou pas forcément
théorique aussi le pff c'est vraiment
génial en mathématiques à ça se
développe
le truc de le pfl ses excès en grosse
grosse croissance contrats notamment par
rapport aux autres universités en europe
je pense que le pfl je mettrai une pièce
en sur le préfet l'enseigné
si les universités les chevaux et qu'il
fallait paris sur un cheveu sur un
cheval tu parles grave peut-être sur les
people mathieu leonetti me demande si
j'ai envie de faire des crossover avec
michael o'neill jj david doit apprendre
ou bruce benamran si vous pouvez tous
les contacts et leur dire de faire du
crossover avec moi
j'adorerais en fait tu n'as pas mal dans
le tas en fait que j'aie jamais
rencontré commencer par en fait il que
david que j'ai rencontré paris les 4
acquis sans citer de guerre viendra les
rencontrer pas ces gens que j'admire
énormément je sors sur la vague qu'ils
ont initiée
je suis j'ai vu toutes leurs vidéos
j'adore ce qu'ils font oui bien ses
organes de vraies saveurs avec malo de
quelen me demande quelle est la
différence entre un mathématicien est
quelqu'un qui fait de physique
fondamentale qu il pas non plus
sérieusement la différence entre eux et
veut oublier parce que je pense qu'il ya
peut-être plus de différence entre
certains mathématicien que des
différences entre certains bateaux
matière et certains certaines personnes
qui ont la physique fondamentale
moi personnellement je suis à ma came
attiser un peu au rythme en un pic est
donc tout ce que tout ce qui est
théorique des nombres et groupe
d'olivier brault dolly et torino j'ai
tout ça tous les trucs sont très proches
de la physique fondamentale
je ne maîtrise pas du tout pensé les
trucs qui me dépasse beaucoup et je vous
promets qu'un jour je comprendrais
théorie quantique des champs mes pensées
je la comprends pas du tout inversement
je suis beaucoup plus proche de
l'informatique théorique et je suis
beaucoup plus ce qui se passe au niveau
de l'informatique loric qu'au niveau
physique on a un mental donc il ya
vraiment beaucoup de 10 de
mathématiciens différents et puis même
auchan au sein des mathématiques pures
il ya déjà différents aspects des
mathématiques pures et les gens qui sont
plus hajeb replu s'analyse truc
géométrie plus combinatoire il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de beaux coups de
mathématiques vous dire tune divers
entre un mathématicien physicien
fondamental c'est tellement négligeable
devant le fait qu'il ya déjà des
différences fondamentales dans la
manière de penser entre des entrées des
mathématiciens guybet me dis que les
passionnés de science et qu'il kiffe
etienne klein bienvenue au club mais son
niveau de maths
d'après lui on peut il veut savoir par
où commencer
il y aussi julien qui demandent si j'ai
des astuces et des conseils à donner
pour mieux comprendre mes vidéos je vais
pas répéter tout ce que j'ai dit dans
l'épisode sur comment devenir fort en
mathématiques mais en bref il ya
vraiment pas de recette miracle il faut
galéré
il faut se poser les questions et puis
je pense qu'il faut surtout avant tout
cherché à vraiment comprendre et ne pas
se satisfaire de ça marche ça marche ça
suffit pas que voir comprendre pourquoi
est ce que ça marche vraiment être
vraiment vouloir vouloir comprendre et
du coup il faut prendre son temps c'est
ça va pas arriver d'un coup comme ça
faut prendre du temps et du coup pour
mes vidéos en particulier
regardez les plusieurs fois vraiment ça
va beaucoup beaucoup vous aider quand je
sais gré qui ont dit ça dans les
commentaires
moi dans le genre vous avez sont vues
tant sur la série aura été bien que me
suis beaucoup inspiré de psp stan qui
ont une excellente chaîne qui est
beaucoup plus rigoureuse et qui va
beaucoup plus loin que beaucoup de
chaînes youtube qui parle et général
d'astrophysique et beaucoup dé vie
d'homme était incompréhensible à
première écoute heures parfois que
j'écoutais la vidéo sur le gall mc2
depuis billet spécial j'ai pas compris
il ya plein de choses que j'ai pas
compris il ya plein de choses qui m'ont
échappé et cette vidéo j'ai dû la voir
trois à quatre fois
j'ai aussi lu le papier original
d'einstein et c'est au bout de toutes
ces lectures relecture visionnage et
visionnage que j'ai commencé à beaucoup
mieux comprendre ce qui se passait puis
ce n'est pas seulement cette vidéo qui
m'a aidé c'est la définition d'une
inertie donc à présent il ya des vidéos
excellente de veritas yonne sur
l'inertie et ce en combinant tout ça que
ma compréhension de la chose a beaucoup
évolué comme donc une vidéo de 10
minutes de qualité comme ça depuis le s
p ce thème ne prend pas dix minutes à
être comprise il faut beaucoup plus de
temps et je vous encourage vraiment à
essayer de prendre le temps à essayer de
voir des vidéos et à essayer de les
revoir et pas forcément juste juste
après c'était pas à revoir aussi les
vidéos un mois six mois après un an
après je fais ça avec beaucoup de vidéos
que j'ai pas forcément comprise et sa
dette beaucoup à date jusqu'à
aujourd'hui j'ai lu croit quatre
bouquins et demi de théorie quantique
des champs mais j'ai toujours pas
compris mais je ne désespère pas je
pense que je finis par le comprend dans
le l'espère mais pour refléter passé
c'est difficile vous galérez mais plus
on arrive à comprendre
puisse allah vite ensuite de comprendre
des nouvelles choses
l'esprit s'adapte de plus en plus en
plus capable d'englober des nouvelles
connaissances c'est ça qui est trop cool
et c'est pour ça que je vous encourage
vraiment regarder les vidéos soient
aussi pour ça que je fais des vidéos
aussi compliquée que celle que je fais
c'est parce que je pense qu'il est très
utile d'être exposés à des trucs très
compliqué et puis de leurs voix à voir
revoir de les connecter à d'autres
vidéos et c'est là qu'on fait beaucoup
de progrès et je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus efficace d'avoir quelques
vidéos vous voyez plusieurs fois que
vous comprenez vraiment des vidéos
difficile comme ça plutôt que de
regarder boomerang deux vidéos qui sont
très tout très simple à comprendre
il faut que la difficulté quelque part
si vous voulez vraiment progresser dans
la compréhension des mathématiques de la
physique du monde entoure et dont on
fait de tout en général alors ça me
bounoua me demande quel est le statut
des objets mathématiques sont ils pris
le produit de l'esprit humain ou
existe-t-il réellement dans un monde à
part transcendant wheelman ans située en
dehors de la caverne de platon livré
science m'oppose à peu près une question
similaire on revient en tout cas qu'ils
demandent est ce que tu penses que les
mathématiques sont des inventions ou des
découvertes des questions absolument
passionnante et j'ai pas envie de rêver
de gâcher vacances de merde maintenant
si je veux pas me donner une réponse de
merde moi je ne suis pas plate auditions
je pense pas qu'ils existent ne réalité
souvent inaccessibles tout ça je pense
que les maths ça se construit pour ça
que je suis dans un laboratoire
d'informatique
j'aime bien de construire des choses
mais à la fin ce que j'ai indiqué c'est
la plupart coin de merde et il vous
donnerai respect à une bien meilleure
réponse dans un futur épisode ce soir
puisqu'on va en parler dans cette série
sur l'infini 2 est ce que les
mathématiques ont une réalité objective
indépendante de tout le monde du monde
réel livré sens me demande aussi quel
est mon théorème mathématique favori une
question qui est également posée par
théo boulanger tavoris un peu difficile
a répondu à beaucoup beaucoup de thé aux
ânes que j adore j'ai fait une vidéo un
leader récemment sur le théorème de
rolle et moi j'adore les ports and roll
parce que c'est une trivialité
absolument pas être idéales c'est un
trick c'est évident comme je vous
rappelle juste rapidement c'est une
prenez deux points qui ont la même
hauteur vous tracez une courbe qui va du
coup d'un point à l'autre et bien le
terrain de rugby il ya un endroit où
courbe va être plate trace une tangente
à la courbe sera horizontale vous pouvez
voir la vidéo si vous voulez en savoir
plus et pour moi c'est un homme qui est
évident mais absolument pas évident
parce que pour prouver cette dame il
faut des notions incroyablement
sophistiqués ce n'est qu'à la fin du dix
neuvième siècle début du xxème que ces
questions là ont commencé à vraiment
être bien mieux comprise notamment parce
qu'avant vous savez impasse descoings
dans le réel
il faut comprendre un nombre égal pour
contrer auteur que j'adore le tour de
rôle pour ça de là à dire que son auteur
ait préféré je sais pas il ya des toiles
que je trouve activement géniaux ce haut
niveau de recherche nyatto m en théorie
algorithmique des jeux saintot m
c'est un peu difficile a expliqué mme en
gros c'est un tome qui dit que le
problème de théorie l'idée de la
conception des mécanismes bayésienne
trop difficile à comprendre et c'est un
tome qui est absolument stupéfiant
j'étais très très surpris quand j'ai vu
l'annoncé je croyais pas puis l'élu se
taper la preuve qu' une preuve qui fait
passer de deux thèses du mighty sim
provoqué plus de 100 points contre
monstrueux c'est une très très grosse
fois vous prouver un truc très très
surprenant mais dont le théorème est un
truc que j'aurais pu faire mieux comme
conjectures en fait j'aurais conjecturer
que l'atmosphère l'opposé de ce qu'il
faut le prouver
et du coup c'est antoine qui m'a
vraiment ce qu'il fait pour ça c'est ça
avait quand même quelques surprenants
que j'ai appris des symptômes très
récent aussi c'est pour ça aussi que
vous voulez le site et si il ya plein de
mathématiques qui sont créés tous les
joueurs c'est vraiment un domaine
incroyablement dynamique aujourd'hui la
recherche mathématique
sinon à titre personnel mon théorème
préféré dans l'est du mont à 6 ans
victorine que j'éprouvais bien sûr il ya
un biais sentimentale parce que
j'éprouve un curran qui dit que les sous
des hypothèses toujours vérifier en
pratique il existe un et un seul
vainqueur dé condorcet de condorcet des
loteries
ça c'est un terme que je trouve
absolument merveilleux si je pouvais
revenir dans le passé et parler à un
scientifique de l'histoire
ça se passera de taille sans doute
limiter les excès
mais à part einstein ce serait sans
doute d'orsay qui est pas le plus grands
mathématiciens
mais c'est un mec incroyable c'est un
mec bien
contrairement à beaucoup de newton ou
galilée tous ont déjà insupportable que
j'aimerais pas forcément compris
condorcet lui c'est un mec j'aimerais
vraiment j'aurais vraiment aimé
rencontrer cherche toujours à aller
vraiment aimé lui montrer mon théorème
et je suis sûr qu'il aurait adoré qui
serait ça serait hydroxyque leur oxydes
me demande s'il vaut mieux apprendre
avant de comprendre ou essayer de
comprendre avant d'apprendre
sachant qu'en prépa vous n'avez pas le
temps de comprendre c'est tout à fait
d'accord avec ça et qui vaut mieux
parfois juste appliqué et en fait
parfois juste en appliquant fini par
comprendre
dans l'idéal but des mathématiques c'est
de comprendre après malheureusement en
pratique vous avez des contraintes et
notamment c'est important d'intégrer une
bonne école
je ne vais pas vous encourager à changer
notre fonction d'objectifs est à dire
son importance et comprendre alors que
l'école intégrer une école qui est
important aussi
en effet en prépa il ya un très bref a
trouvé entre comprend on a juste savoir
appliquer parfois c'est bien triste
c'est super triste je trouve après je
pense à même qu' il n'y a pas assez
d'efforts de compréhension qui est fait
de la part des étudiants en général et
en prépa également parce que beaucoup
trop de gens ont les poches contente
d'apprendre comprendre prend plus de
temps mais parfois sur le long terme ça
beaucoup ça permet d'aller beaucoup plus
vite après pour apprendre de nouveaux
trucs et savoir appliquer et résoudre
des problèmes plus rapidement
donc pour comprendre hydroxyque roxy de
me demande plutôt algèbre au plus tôt
analyse mois à la prépa en tout cas j'ai
été à fond analyse je préférais
largement l'analyse parce que c'est
beaucoup plus tactique que vous sent
plus les choses c'est des raisonnements
pour rester plus des raisonnements qu'il
fallait vraiment plus réfléchir pour
faire de l'analyse c'est plus vrai en
substance p ans p malheureusement
pendant que le toit ne convertit en 2001
qui fait partie de l'année
c'est un terme que j'ai jamais compris
aujourd'hui encore se comprend pas et
pas trop d'incitatifs à chercher à
comprendre
malheureusement pratiquement c'est un
exemple de turenne que j'ai juste appris
à appliquer jamais compris de ma vie et
ça c'est l'analyse que j'aimais pas il
faut juste appliqué puis qu'on ait
beaucoup de formules de dérouler c'est
chiant que vers ça bien c'est long ça
c'est chiant c'est nul mais l'analyse de
prépa karan rolls dorée qu'un type comme
ça puis pour formaliser ensuite
l'intuition c'est ce que j'adorais c'est
que les poèmes dan ellis bien souvent
fallait d'abord cherché à comprendre le
problème comprendre l'intuition derrière
certains traits et puis dès qu'on avait
l'intuition fallait ensuite la
formaliser j'adorais aussi cet effort de
formalisation de l'intuition terre
vérifie que l'institution est juste en
donnant une prof hormis son ca
j'adorerais faire ça et ensuite on était
convaincu de rester
j'ai rangé j'adorais ça donc j'étais
carrément plus analyseur que pour moi
l'algèbre avait l'air d'être magique
magic bon sens où j'arrive pas à
comprendre et ça ça me frustrait un
petit peu et puis je voulais quand elle
gère aussi avait moins d'incitatifs à
vouloir comprendre en fait ça suffisait
juste de manipuler les formules et au
bout d'un moment ça ne marchait pas
c'est un peu un sudoku
bon ça va finir par marcher pour essayer
c'est lorsque gilles ne sortait pas
vraies élections vraiment bon en algèbre
ils ont leurs intuitions de l'algèbre
ils arrivent à avoir quelqu un qu il
faut faire très rapidement mais c'était
pas mon cas quand j'étais en prépa c'est
un peu plus mon cas aujourd'hui hier je
comprends mieux l'algèbre aujourd'hui du
coup j'apprécie plus âgés j'apprécie
beaucoup plus sage et vocalement c'est
en ce très joli à desvres je pense que
je reste quand même un petit peu plus
analytique mais même si l'analyse au
niveau c'est difficile beaucoup de
détails à celle ci il faut vraiment être
torturés d'esprit pour faire des
analyses à très haut niveau
moi mon truc que j'aime vraiment plus
c'est plus les probabilités aujourd'hui
font plus sur les probabilités pause
mais tire ma thèse aussi
beaucoup de probabilités et j'adore le
raisonnement probabiliste je trouve
qu'il ya vraiment un truc génial
derrière tout ça et qui super pas
intuitif et quand qu'on comprend quand
on commence à avoir l'intuition de ce
qu'il y de ce moment fait je pense qu'on
voit vraiment le monde différemment
hydroxy coxyde me demande aussi de
présenter une curiosité ou un domaine
mathématiques et qui est soit vraiment
très étrange ou étonnant alors rentré
que j'ai découvert récemment par
récemment je vous dis avec quelques
semaines quelques mois
c'est une ville hauts de fully boulot en
béarn sur ce il appelle trigger loft
arbres de cris angle de puissance et
j'écris un article sainte-flore l'oci là
dessus en anglais malheureusement et
c'est un truc que je comprends moins
génial que l'idée c'est que on a trois
façons différentes décrire le fait que
deux au cube est égal à 8 on peut faire
deux avec 1,3 euro égale 8 claire de la
racine cubique de 8 signes bizarres des
galas deux et on peut écrire leurs bases
de 2,8 égale à 3 qui est sans doute la
notation la plus bizarre de tout et en
fait c'est trop notation décrivent la
même chose mais quand les apprend il
même avant d'avoir vu la vidéo je n'ai
même pas vu le lien entre ces trois
expressions notamment entre racine
cubique et le log
c'est l'air d'être de trucs complètement
différents mais en fait ça dit
exactement la même chose et tout ce que
ça dit c'est qu'il ne relation
particulière entre le 2 le 3 et le 8 et
cette relation particulière plutôt que
les cuire avec une égalité avec de
signes d'un côté un autre signe de
l'autre basse riboud loin de bornes ou
plutôt ça commençait sur un port un truc
de maps times un truc très internet ce
qui est cool aussi
la proposition qu'ils ont fait c'est
d'écrire ça sous la forme d'un triangle
du coup la clique de triangle et
l'identité remarquable en lui-même pme
superbe identités remarquables et du
coup à ce triangle de 3,8 on pourra
ensuite faire d'autres opérations si on
veut mettre un des trucs à droite dont
injuste ont mieux à droite du sénégal et
puis qu'on peu froid écrire tout
l'algèbre et toute l'analyse avec ça et
ça fait des équations super jolie qui je
pense permettent de bien mieux
comprendre les halls vélo le car est une
exposition
je pense que l'utilisation du triangle
puis on se permet de bien me comprendre
tout ça est ce que un jour on écrira
tout fait mathématique à l'aide de ce
triangle je l'espère c'est à dire mais
je l'espère vraiment et j'espère qu'un
jour on utilisera cette fois rendu cette
notation plutôt que les expériences et
les lobbys réduit les radicaux sinon un
domaine de recherche est un peu bizarre
en train de réfléchir un petit peu il ya
un truc qui dit non j'ai déjà assisté
une présentation bon truc super
appliquées ou c'était comment arranger
des colis dans un camion sachant que bon
on les range par le fond plat et donc il
ya plein de problèmes de taille et tout
ça nous c'est sympa mais c'est marrant
qui se font ou un algorithme qui a de
tout ça et puis que vous puissiez de
prouver des taux à 1 par rapport à tout
ça ce qui est marrant c'est qu'en fait
c'est écrit c'est du super pétrissent
enfin dernière question seb 16 120 me
demande quelles sont mes projets futurs
j'aimerais bien continuer à faire des
vidéoconférences encore une fois c'est
je pense que c'est la meilleure façon de
communiquer les mathématiques et de
donner un engouement pour les
mathématiques pour améliorer toutes les
connaissances en mathématiques et je
pense que les mathématiques notamment le
raisonnement mathématique pas faire des
calculs mathématiques et peut-être même
pas faire des preuves et juste à voir la
façon de raisonner de mathématiques de
se dire qu'il faut faire une preuve que
je pense que ça peut largement
contribuer à rendre les gens plus
capable de réfléchir par eux-mêmes et à
conduire à moins d'idées aussi on va
dire à plus grande échelle
du coup je pense que l'enseignement des
mathématiques c'est super important et
de l'informatique théorique alors parce
que je pense que l'informatique
théorique notamment l'algorithmique sont
des façons de penser qu'ils sont
absolument génial que tous devraient non
seulement avoir appris même saisir dans
sa tête
vraiment avoir des réflexes
algorithmique de penser algorithme qui
dans sa tête je pense que ce serait
vraiment génial si plus de gens avaient
se voir de façon de penser et c'est pour
ça que je suis mes vidéos je pense que
ça peut vraiment améliorer le monde en
général
ces façons de penser son mieux comprise
de beaucoup de gens et aussi de diminuer
j'espère les incompréhensions et les
malentendus je pense que c'est super
important de faire des rotations en
mathématiques en fait je fais ça pour
d'abord parce que je kiffe ça mais aussi
parce que je pense que c'est la chose la
plus éthique que je pourrais faire
malheureusement j'ai un contrat qui ne
dure que six mois nous qui devra finir
dans quelques mois donc je sais pas si
je serai à renouveler on verra mais il
ya des projets qui se montrent pour
l'instant je peux pas plus vous en dire
mais bon là je vous remercie pour toutes
ces questions j'espère que si vous avez
trouvé ça intéressant et puis j'espère
surtout que vous continuerez à me suivre
sur scène ce roll et qu'on sera de plus
en plus nombreux à aimer pensée
mathématique au moins une fois par
semaine